Trump versus the establishment i'm jason
chaffetz in tonight for Shawn just 24
hours ago many in the mainstream media
were openly mocking President Trump for
losses in the stock market and
ridiculing him for not visiting our
troops during the Christmas season once
again the destroyed Trump press looks a
bit foolish today the stock market
bounced back with a record single day
point gain and president Trump along
with the first lady Melania Trump spent
the day with our troops after a surprise
visit to a rock where he shared his
gratitude for all of America's brave
servicemen and women watch this thank
you and every service member throughout
this region for the near elimination of
the ISIS territorial Caliphate in Iraq
and in Syria two years ago when I became
president they were a very dominant
group they were very dominant today
they're not so dominant anymore
on his way back from Iraq president
Trump visited US soldiers in Germany
we'll keep you updated on his surprise
trip throughout the show but first
joining us now with reaction the author
of why we fight Fox News national
security strategist Sebastian Gorka
former press secretary for vice
president prince and member of the Trump
2020 advisory board Marc Lauder and from
The Wall Street Journal one of my
personal favorites Kimberly Straus all
thank you all three of you for joining
us on this beautiful night in this great
holiday season I want to start with dr.
Gorka here the president is out there I
think one of the great strengths of the
president has been his foreign policy
but there have been some moves what's
the signal and the message that the
president is trying to portray out there
to the world well Merry Christmas Jason
it's a very simple one it is the
antithesis of the previous eight years
under the Obama White House remember
under that administration we had
concepts such as leading from behind
which is of course in oxymoron and
strategic patience allowing others to
take the initiative built into the
foreign policy of the United States
basically America withdrew from the
world and allow
others like Putin like Isis like China
like Iran to take the initiative and
destabilize the globe what you saw today
I spoke with the White House yesterday
as a president when his was on his way
to Iraq what you see is an expression of
American leadership reasserted whether
it's saying in Syria look we've done
what we came to do the Caliphate is
destroyed now others have to pick up the
load or whether it is spending your
Christmas as commander-in-chief with the
first lady the first time ever the first
lady in my understanding has visited
Iraq since 9/11 taking your Christmas
celebration and taking it to the Troops
and that amazing moment that Sarah
Huckabee Saunders shared with us when
one of our servicemen said to the
president I came back into the armed
services because of You mr. president
and his response was what I am here now
in Iraq because of you that's the make
America great again way and that's
Donald Trump now mark what does it tell
us about the perspective from the
international community we are the
world's pre-eminent superpower so what
is the message of President Trump is
putting out there by being on the ground
himself in Iraq I think if it's a strong
message that the president has our ala
has on the backs of our soldiers and our
airmen and our sailors no matter where
they're stationed in the world and he
showed that he demonstrated that and
this is a president who's also stood
with them by rebuilding our military and
so much emphasis has been placed today
on the launch of the hypersonic missile
over in in Russia this is a president
now who saw our military decimated under
the Obama administration
he stood up he's rebuilding our military
he is putting us in a position where we
can defend ourselves and our allies
around the world and our enemies know it
at Kim there's been a lot of discussion
certainly over the last week with the
moves in Syria and whatnot but is it
this also about Iran I mean the
proximity cannot get lost we hear almost
nothing being mentioned about Iran and
the message that this might send to the
Iranians and the Europeans and others
about our positioning on Iran how do
read into that well that's why this was
so important because coming on the back
of the announcements about Syria and
Afghanistan the worry was of course at
the message it was being sent to Iran
was that we were not certain about our
commitment in key areas in that region
and by going there by making it clear
we're not withdrawing from Iraq we're
not stopping the fight against Isis and
we're not seeding the territory and the
regional control to Iran that is a good
message for the president to assent but
can I just add something Jason sure I
think it would be worthwhile just
there's all this focus right now on what
this means and the president's rough
week and the press has all been
struggling and focusing on that this is
just a straightforward story of a
president going over to visit the troops
saying hello which is a customary thing
to do and we should be celebrating it
for that in and of itself so mark do you
think we're going to see a lot of
Corrections on the front pages of the
newspapers and talk shows across the
country is that going to happen no
absolutely not they're already picking
apart every word that he said and to
Kim's point the only video and the only
audio we really need to hear is are
those troops who were chanting USA USA
when the president and first lady walked
in there they loved their
commander-in-chief in Donald Trump you
know dr. Gorka wanted that I think the
important messages to the troops is that
we as Americans all of us Americans no
matter your political stripes that we
stand behind the troops it was it's just
a photo-op I mean the criticism is hey
Donald Trump didn't go there and then as
soon as he goes there they say oh it's
just for a photo-op what does this mean
and what is the message that President
Trump is saying to the men and women and
their families who put their lives in
line for our United States military and
for this country Jason it has nothing to
do the photo opportunity it's it was
leaked so now I can discuss it in the
second month of the administration we
had 18 future Green Berets visiting the
eeob the Eisenhower building next to the
White House after their visit to the NSC
I took them to meet the president the
president took time out of his schedule
to meet these young officers each one
was
photographed next to the president at
the resolute desk not because those
photographs can be used in public
because these are our cutting-edge Army
Special Forces guys those photographs
never see the light of day but he wanted
to give something to them to give back
to show them that he's so respects
anyone that wears the cloth of the
Republic or law enforcement I've seen it
again and again and again the first
thing the president does when he gets
off Air Force One when there are no
cameras there at that base he gets off
and he goes down and he shakes the hand
of every police outrider to show his
respect this is a man who loves those
people and it makes such a change after
the Obama is know it does and the
president is on the ground as we speak
at the Ramstein Air Force Base there in
the Germany it's the middle of the night
but he's there visiting with troops you
know those Air Force bases are working
24/7 and the president is there on the
ground as we speak Kim I also want to
talk though about the other big news
that happened today which was the stock
market a thousand point gain which is
not a typical day there has been some
volatility on the market how do you read
into that what what are the swings
attributed to and where should investors
look and where are they going the first
thing is it was good news that the White
House came out today and made clear that
the Fed chief Jerome Powell his job was
secure okay because that was some of the
uncertainty that we were seeing out
there but look I think there comes a
point at which the market just steps
back and maybe that's what we saw today
and realize that despite all the talk
about the uncertainty that is out there
on China and trade deals the shutdown
etc that the fundamentals of the economy
remain really strong and we're seeing
that come in really robust holiday sales
we're going to have GDP GDP come in at a
very strong number this year
unemployment remains low all of these
things that are key indicators of
economic strength and manufacturing in
other areas they really are looking good
and hopefully that's what you're seeing
today is a bit of a correction with
regards to the market and the markets
not an indicator of the economy
obviously but it takes its cue from
economic signals and hopefully this is a
return to a little bit of rationality
about the
future and the prospects for us growth
now Marco one of the things the
president also said while he was in Iraq
is that he plans to visit the southern
border what would you like to see the
president do and how does this play into
the shutdown fight then discussions that
we have going on at almost an hourly
basis right now I want to I want to see
him highlight the great work that
Customs and Border Patrol does every day
even during the shutdown to keep out a
little illegal immigration stop gang
members and drugs from flowing into our
country and show the rest of the world
what we who know the statistics no walls
work and it's easy to demonstrate that
through real-life examples and so I
think the president will highlight that
and it will set the stage for not only
the negotiations with Speaker Pelosi but
it will set the stage for a very strong
State of the Union speech that I can
almost guarantee you will have a very
heavy focus on immigration reform
broad-based immigration reform and
securing our borders yeah when the
president gets an hour or two to address
the nation in that State of the Union
affair and he gets to talk in front of
members of Congress I've been there in
the audience to listen eight times to
Barack Obama try to tell me the way the
world was it was a fascinating thing but
dr. Berkey the president's going down to
the southern border what's the message
you would like to see the president
portray well marks right in addition to
recognizing the incredible work of CBP
and ice and everybody that wears uniform
and protects us at the border there's
one very simple message the wall will be
built and the border is a national
security issue Jason you know as well as
anybody else this isn't about you know
illegals who are turned into a voting
base for the Democrats this is about
ms-13 it's about drug trafficking it's
about women who are raped as they come
across the border mine is being handed
into the hands of coyotes this is a
national security issue and that is how
the president is going to represent it
to all of America whether Chuck Schumer
or Nancy likes it or not
no look I think you're absolutely right
and stay tuned with us later in the show
we're gonna talk some more about that in
depth but thank you very much during
this holiday season for joining
here tonight we do appreciate it